so when you start to think about bitcoin
versus gold
would you ever consider i know you're
not a fan of bitcoin we can get to why
but would you buy the bitcoin uh mining
stocks because there's cash flow
no why wait why first of all
it's cash flowing mining stocks first of
all let's
like like look they don't mind anything
what are you talking about equipment
there they solve math problems
but the problem is they use a lot of
energy to solve those problems
uh but i wouldn't want to buy any of
these things because when the price of
bitcoin crashes
these stocks are worthless because it's
going to cost more to mine them
than you could get for them so no i mean
if i
what i would be doing if i was a company
i would be selling stock to any fool
who's gonna buy it from me i'd be like
selling new shares doing secondaries you
know just
trying to dump all it out there but i
don't have any shares
what would it take for you to buy
bitcoin what's the one thing in the
economy
or any sort of uh financial markets
that you would finally say all right
enough is enough i won't tell pomp that
he was right
but i'm gonna go put a little bitcoin
away i'm gonna put under the mattress
not tell anybody about how much you talk
about play money like i would buy like
you know a lottery ticket or something
but have you done that yet
have you have you even speculated a
little bit bought even just one just for
fun
i mean you're about you're almost a
billionaire i have not i have bought a
couple of lottery tickets in my life
well did you buy bitcoin as a lottery
ticket yet
no i haven't bought any bitcoin all
right so you haven't bought anything
what would cause you to buy
given me people have given me some
bitcoin or fractions of a bitcoin but i
lost them all as you know
yeah so well you didn't lose just over
clear you didn't lose unfortunately my
son has actually bought some
you didn't lose the bitcoin you lost the
password which is user error i lost
access to them right i know where they
are i know but i just can't
i just can't get out holding on to the
bitcoin is an intelligence test if you
lose the password it can't help you
right
it's like losing the password to your
brokerage account sorry i never had the
password to lose that was a problem
all right what would it take to get you
to buy one bitcoin
just one bitcoin where you actually took
dollars and converted it into bitcoin
what would be the thing in the market
that you would finally say all right i
got to do this
well look right now they're what like 33
000 34 000 i never i wouldn't want to
waste 34
000 on a bitcoin so um
you know i mean i could buy a lot of
other things with that money i mean i
suppose if the price got
cheap enough maybe if it got back i
don't know below a buck maybe i could
buy
it
so the question is you know would i want
one see this is the thing
i mean if you could say all right i've
talked to a lot of these bitcoin
huddlers and they're like oh yeah i
would want to buy so many more
really if it really got down that low
wouldn't that be a signal i mean is
there a point
you know for you bob you're asking me
when i would buy my bitcoin
i mean i don't really know because i i'm
not interested in it but the real
question is
what will it take to get you to sell
gold gold
to 500 would you buy more if gold went
to 500 dollars
well sure okay but here's the reason why
because gold is an actual commodity is
it
and and so yes there's a lot of fake
gold i
i want to talk to you about fake gold i
saw on the internet there's all kinds of
fake gold
in space yeah well so fake gold doesn't
do what real gold does
i don't know if you you know so but how
did you know how old does it have
how do you know you have real gold you
like are you a chemist are you are you
testing it
yeah it's not you know that's part of
the lies that the bitcoin pumpers tell
is that it's hard to know real gold from
fake gold well how do you been able to
tell
real gold from fake gold for thousands
of years and they didn't even have any
technology
they didn't even we it's so much easier
to tell the difference between real gold
and fake gold now
than we were on the gold standard so
this is all a bunch of nonsense
but the answer your question see since
gold is an actual commodity
let's say i am a jewelry manufacturer
and i
i know i got demand to make jewelry
which by the way is only
is less than 10 of all demand and demand
for jewelry has been dropping but go
ahead
yeah yeah i don't know i don't i don't
know who you're dating but anyway
so if the price of
gold goes down to 500 and i'm a jeweler
i'm like whoa
i can buy a bunch of gold that i need
much cheaper to make these
necklaces or these rings or these
whatever and so there's going to be more
demand
right if i'm if i need gold in my
computer chips and all of a sudden the
price goes down now i can buy more gold
for the same money
and put them in my chips and save money
i'm going to buy more
right there's there's a way to
rationalize that like if i have a stock
i talked
earlier about a stock let's say there's
a stock that i love
at ten dollars a share and it's got a
five percent dividend yield at ten
dollars a share
if the stock drops to five and now i got
and now
you know or it had a five percent
dividend and now it gets cut in half
and now the dividend is ten percent i
get twice the dividend yield
by buying it at half the price whatever
value of the assets was there
all else being equal i can buy those
same assets
for half price when it comes to bitcoin
i don't get any more
when i buy bitcoin at 10 000 than when i
buy it at 30 000 yeah i buy
i get more bitcoin but i don't get any
more dividends because it doesn't pay
any dividends i don't get any more rent
like i buy real estate on sale and i
can't make any more jewelry
because i've got more bitcoin because
you can't make anything with a bitcoin
doesn't matter how many you have i can
have all 21 million bitcoins
and i can't do anything that i couldn't
do with just one
doesn't matter how many you have but the
more gold you have the more electricity
you can conduct the more jewelry you can
make whatever all that stuff you could
do
uh and so there is no way to know that
bitcoin is cheap because there's nothing
to measure it against so my question to
you is
you think bitcoin is gonna be the new
money it's going to you know
replace gold or replace other people
it's already replaced gold just
somewhere clear it's already replaced
gold for people under the age of 35.
nobody owns gold under the age of 35.
it hasn't replaced gold in the real
world
it hasn't replaced gold in jewelry it
hasn't that the central banks still own
gold as part of a monetary asset
they were net sellers in q4 go ahead yes
but
you believe that all this stuff is going
to happen to bitcoin and
it all hinges on you know more adoption
you know just like we talked about
social security being a ponzi scheme
it's kind of the same dynamic
you're talking you're talking about gold
right gold's price only goes up if more
people want gold right
and that's how it works but people want
gold for all the properties that gold
has but but it's demand-based the only
reason why any asset hold on the only
reason why any asset goes up is because
it's demand-based
if more people don't want apple stock it
goes down if more people don't want gold
it goes down
if more people don't want bitcoin it
goes down that's how the markets work
it's called supply and demand i'll send
you economics one-on-one
apple if people want to buy apple
products
and apple's earning a profit and paying
a dividend well people will want to buy
the stock
now you know obviously in a different
environment with higher interest rates
they may not be willing to pay as much
for apple stock as they're paying now
but there will be demand at some price
for apple stock that's not the case with
bitcoin i mean at gold
even if you don't want to buy gold at
1800 you might want to buy it at a
thousand
because it may be a good deal for what
you needed for uh but bitcoin
is is not a commodity and it's not an
investable asset it doesn't it doesn't
have a use
and it doesn't throw off an income
stream so again to get back to the
question i'm asking you
you think that bitcoin is going to
continue to
be adopted and more institutions are
going to buy it
more people around the world are going
to start using it what if that doesn't
happen
right at some point so let's say bitcoin
crashes
to to 20 000 or then 10 000 or then
5 000 right is there some point where
you like kind of like all right i was
wrong
it's not catching on the momentum has
turned
i'm just going to give up on this i'm
not going to go down with the ship to
zero
is there a point where you get out i
mean what if unicorns
fall from the sky right no no no no
listen that's a
crazy if it continues bitcoin if it
continues bitcoin going to 10
000 is not crazy bitcoin was at 10 000 a
year ago
to say that bitcoin can't go back to 10
000 again is ridiculous well you're
probably
my point hold on bitcoin was change your
view
so bitcoin was 10 000 a year ago and now
it's at 35.
and for bitcoin to go from 35 to 10
about 70 percent 75 whatever the number
is right
yeah i'm sorry that means that we would
just return to prices not seen since
last year
if gold fell 75 it would be
numbers from literally 30 years ago no
it wouldn't change my mind here's why i
wouldn't change my mind ready
everything that you say about the
economy i think generally you and i
agree right we agree that the
uh fed's lost their mind they're
manipulating markets
uh people are getting hurt nobody
understands that they should be
investing rather than saving all the
things that you say about the economy we
agree on
you and i both also agree that sound
money
is the solution right we can't have
money that can just be printed at will
because politicians or other folks
decide that we're going to do that
or we're going to manipulate those
markets so sound money is the solution
there's
okay well just so we're clear their
sound money is the definition of sound
money is that it's outside the system
and no one can create more of it and so
golden
first of all let me pump do you know
the origin of the word sound money do
you know where it comes from it's not a
spelling bee but go ahead tell me
well so if you take a gold coin and you
drop it on a hard surface
it makes a sound as opposed to when you
drop
a piece of paper on a surface it doesn't
make a sound
so hard money makes a sound when you
drop it
what's the sound that bitcoin makes when
you drop it
peter do you hear this this is like
blockbuster saying to netflix oh you
have no value because when we drop the
vhs
tape on the table it makes a sound
that's ridiculous there's a difference
see
see when i can watch a video that still
has
value i watching a video on television
i mean on let's do a race all right hold
on we're gonna set it
here's my challenge to you ready you
want to see what has more value
you send me a gold bar i'll send you a
bitcoin and we'll see who gets there
first
that's irrelevant because i can first of
all i don't have any bitcoin to send you
no no you send me the gold bar
the goal i mean you could put it in the
mail it'll take you seven days to get it
too yeah but i would be sending you
something real the reason it's so cheap
to send bitcoin is because you're
sending nothing
if i'm gonna send nothing yeah i can
send nothing real cheap
but come back to this question i'm
asking you right
at where do you throw in the towel
on bitcoin and say no you're wrong
get rid of it i mean if it's not ten
thousand what if it goes to one thousand
if bitcoin is at one thousand if we're
doing an interview
in the future and bitcoin is one
thousand
are you gonna say well if you bought it
when it was a dollar you still have a
thousand times your money
peter's the best performing or are you
gonna admit you were wrong
the the difference is that bitcoin is
going to be the global reserve currency
because nobody can create more of it and
it is already becoming the digital
reserve currency of that digital economy
and the whole key to this is the reason
why you're so worried about
price is because gold will never be the
global reserve currency ever again
it's over we're not going back to a gold
standard but there is a much higher
likelihood
that we transition to a bitcoin reward
uh reserves
uh status and when that happens the u.s
dollar exchange value doesn't matter
right it doesn't matter
because just one bitcoin equals one
bitcoin here here's the problem with the
gold thesis
is that they printed trillions of
dollars every asset in the planet
literally beanie babies went up in value
and gold didn't go up in value in the
last 12 months yeah so gold today is
worth less than it was
last year because it didn't even keep up
with inflation
if i was holding gold my gold didn't
even keep up with inflation
yeah that's because we have a bubble in
everything gold is money
right so you have a bubble stocks are
overpriced
real estate is overpriced in terms of
money gold is not currency
gold is actual money currency was backed
by money
the first legitimate currency was a
receipt for gold gold was the money that
backed up the currency that's what gave
currency value
was that it was backed up by gold now
fiat currency
is currency backed up by nothing that's
like what bitcoin is bitcoin is backed
by nothing it has no
actual value when you say that they're
not you know they there's a limit to how
many
there's almost 11 000 cryptocurrencies
now
i mean the supply is growing uh you know
like wildflower
there is no limit to the number of
virtually identical cryptocurrencies
that can be created and they keep
creating them and
you think there's a limit to 21 million
bitcoin maybe there is maybe there isn't
it doesn't even matter
how many bitcoins there are it matters
is how many other cryptocurrencies could
people buy
instead of bitcoin because there's
nothing special about bitcoin
other than the name and it's not even
that special because you got bitcoin
cash you got bitcoin gold you got
whatever bitcoin this bitcoin that i
mean what's the difference there's
really
there really is no difference when you
basically you know take a step back and
look at
look at what you got the the odds of
bitcoin becoming the reserve asset for
the world are
zero it's never gonna happen that's a
fantasy
peter i love you i just want to remind
you of one fact as your friend
because i feel like it's important that
you remember this if you had sold your
gold
and bought bitcoin in the last 12 months
or when you first heard about it you
would be a billionaire today
well there's look if i had put all of my
net worth
into bitcoin when i first heard about it
yeah no not your whole net worth
not your whole net worth just you had
replaced your gold allocation with
bitcoin allocation yes i would i would
be a
billionaire if i did that when i first
heard about it or in the last year
or if you did it in the last year you'd
probably still be able to that applies
but that applies to a lot of people
not just me probably applies to you when
you first heard about bitcoin if you put
all your
money in it you'd probably be a
billionaire too no i'm not talking about
all your money i'm talking about just
gold